hello everyone welcome to another tambo
technique class at home
i hope you are all doing fine today we
will work on our autumns forward
and we will use the two main techniques
to execute them
which are hip first or leg first
yeah if you remember from the last video
the two techniques are the opposite of
each other hip first
means that the rotation of your hip
is the first movement that we do and
this rotation
causes the movement of your free leg and
leg first
is the opposite is when the movement
of your free leg is the first movement
that you do you start by moving the leg
and the movement of the leg causes the
rotation of the hip
so the two techniques are the opposite
of each other if you think about it
it's all about how you achieve the
new direction for the next step yeah
you know that in double peabodys
are the movements that we use to change
the direction of our next step
so these two techniques have to do with
how
do you reach this new direction the
first technique
keep first is the most common
because it follows the chain
in your body that goes from the torso
to the hip to the leg usually the torso
is the first part of your body that
looks in the new direction
especially if you are the follower
yeah you will be led to look in this
direction and then
the next part in your body is the hip so
the hip is the next
thing that goes into the into the new
direction with the standing leg of
course
and then the free leg is the last thing
but there is this second technique
leg first in which after the torso looks
in the new direction
then in instead of going torso
hip leg you go torso leg hip
after the torso you move the leg and
then after the leg
you move the hip so the hip is the last
one yeah
so it's a bit longer but it feels very
good when you do it
and it gives your autos a very
um very cool character very special
character
okay so today we will start with our
warm up
and then we will do a series of
exercises with doctors forward
in which we will use both techniques
hip first and leg first okay good so
let's go to the warm up okay warm up so
put your feet together
and use a few seconds to relax
breathe deeply find your center and
feel the pressure of your feet on the
floor and imagine that the weight of
your body
is just coming down yeah coming down to
the floor
through your feet and we start with
shoulder circles yeah remember
to keep the arms relaxed and not use the
elbows like this yeah just keep the
elbows straight
make the circles big and slow yeah
we do eight one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight and now we do arm circles very
big circles like this remember that the
elbows now have to be straight the whole
time especially when the arms are up
and that when you open the arms to the
side your hands are a little bit behind
your back
so that you really stretch the chest
muscles okay
and we do eight one
two three
four five
six seven
and eight okay now we stretch the side
of our torso so we raise one arm make
sure that it's
straight yeah and then uh
we slide the handle is down on our leg
until we can touch the knee
yeah or if you can go past the knee and
then we hold this stretch
three seconds and then we use the hand
that is up
to pull ourselves vertical again and
then we drop the arm and we repeat with
the other side
okay so let's do it four times to each
side
so one arm up and then one go down
hold it and up and one
arm straight go down hold it
and up two
slide down breathe don't forget to
breathe
relax and
up two arm up
go down breathe hold the stretch
and up three
go down hold it
try every time to go a little bit more
down
and then up three
go down a little bit more if you can
hold it and up and the last one
this side go down slowly
try to go further hold it
and up and forward with this side
go down slowly try to further
hold it and up
okay now we open the legs we bend the
knees slightly
this will help block our hip we make a
circle with the arms
and we rotate the torso left and right
now remember that
when you do this movement the hip and
the head looks straight
you don't move them okay you only move
the torso
and the arms the torso and the back are
one block
and they move together yeah otherwise
you're moving the arms alone without the
back
and then you are not doing work okay
so make a circle and we do twice eight
times to each side
yeah and very relaxed one
two
three and four and
five and six and
seven and eight okay now we
stretch the legs yeah and we grab our
hips and we go
back with our hips like this and then
we bend the back until the back is
parallel with the floor
okay and then from here we drop the head
and the rest of the bag and we bounce
three times
one two three and then we
go up again slowly until we are straight
yeah this is to stretch the back of our
legs which is very useful for example to
achieve a beautiful step and the back
of our hip of our back which will help
our posture okay so let's do it eight
times
slowly bend forward then drop the hand
on the back
bounce three times one two three
and go up this is one
two or down drop
bounce one two three
and go up three
go down one two three
up and four
drop bounce bounce bounce
and go up five
go down bounce bounce bounce
go up six
go down bounce bounce
bounce go up
seven go down
bounce
go up and the last one eight
go down bounce bounce bounce
and go up okay now we bring our hip back
again but not so much as before
because from here keeping the head in
this position
and the knees straight we move our hip
to the side
yeah you should feel a slight stretch on
the inside of this leg that i have on a
leg
yeah and then we go forward and then we
go to the other side
now you feel the stretch here yeah and
then we
reach the start position so we do a full
circle we do it eight times on one
direction
and then eight times on the other
direction okay
so let's move together one
make it very big two
three four
five keep the knees straight six
seven heels on the floor and eight
and now change direction one
two three
four keep the head in one place five
six seven
and eight okay and then straight now we
close the legs
we let go of the arms relax the arms we
bend the knees
we bounce three times very relaxed one
two three
then we stretch the knees and from here
we go
up pushing the floor until we're on the
toes
and the balls of the feet yeah and we
hold it three times
remember keep your core tight in order
to be able to hold it
and then we go down yeah and then we
bounce again we do it eight times
yeah so one balance bounce bounce
stretch knees go up hold it
and down two bunks bounce bounce
go up hold it
down three bounce bounce bounce
go up hold it down
four bounce bounce bounce go up
hold it down five
bounce bounce bounce up
and down six pounds balance bounce
one hold it down
seven bombs bounce bounce
go up hold it and the last one
balance balance bounce and go up
hold it and go down slowly yeah when you
go down
always control don't go down fast
yeah controlled and then we do the last
exercise which is for pivots and the
core
you stand on one leg if you mirror me
now you stand on
on your right that's okay and you make a
circle with the arms
like this yeah like we did for this one
yeah it's the same idea same
position but now the torsion with the
torso will be very small
very small because then we will rotate
the hip
to the same direction the movement of
the torso
is very small and the movement of the
hip is
bigger like this and then from here
we move the torso to the opposite
direction and then we rotate the hip
much more yeah and the whole time you
stand on one foot
yeah so we do eight times to each side
with each foot we start with this foot
and then we do it eight times to each
side
so we start like this and one
two three
four five
six five seven
and eight ah okay
now change the foot
and we do it eight times with this leg
and
one
okay if you have balance problems try to
bend the standing leg a little bit more
yeah then and then that should improve
your stability
okay let's do it eight times more we do
it with this leg now
one two
three four
five six and
okay now we change the leg and we do it
one last time
eight times with this leg uh
one two
three four
five six
seven and eight up
okay good so when i've
finished let's go to the first exercise
okay
in this first exercise we will practice
such a forward with hip
first and we will concentrate on the
movement of the pivot
yeah so each exercise we will do
always twice first supporting ourselves
on the wall
and then without support on our own yeah
now when you support yourself on the
wall remember the tips from the last
video
use only the fingers yeah don't put the
whole hand on the wall
don't raise the elbows and don't lean
into the wall because this will give you
very bad technique
just use the fingers very light pressure
because you should not need the wall
very much and keep the elbows down
and find your axis yeah now the exercise
looks like this you stand
on the left leg you bend the knee
we will use a flex knee during the whole
exercise and then you put the free foot
behind
like this yeah so some distance with
your standing
foot be careful that your heel doesn't
drop
to the outside like this this is bad
form it looks bad
make sure that the hip is straight or
drop it to the inside that's better
yeah so you should be making contact
with the floor with a big
toe yeah the big toes on the floor and
then the first thing you do is you
you rotate the hip yeah you twist the
hip
with a pivot and when you do the pivot
you keep the free foot
behind yeah don't close it in zero
position
during the period keep it behind and
then when the pivot is finished
then you close it in zero position yeah
so that's how the exercise looks like
hip and leg yeah two movements don't mix
them
is hip and leg and then to go back to
the initial position
you do leg and hip yeah hip
leg leg hip hip
leg leg hip okay
now we will do this with the metronome
as usual
the metronome is uh set to
58 bpm two bits per bar
like this one
two one two
yeah and
the way we coordinate the movements of
the exercise with the beat
is like this the one
is the pivot is the twist of the hip one
and then two is the leg two and then to
go back
one is the leg two is the hip yeah
one two one two
okay we will do it eight times like this
and then eight times with the other leg
and then we will repeat it again without
support
okay so let's do it eight times together
with the metronome so get ready
fingers on the wall very light support
engage your middle your torso use the
needle to do the exercise
let's do three times
one
two
three
four
five
okay try not to move the torso too much
yeah move the hip on the mirror not the
torso
yeah and it's very important that you
don't close the foot
during the pivot keep the foot behind
during the whole wheel
okay let's do it with the other leg so
weight on the right
prepare the foot make sure that the heel
is going inside
and the big toe is on the floor and we
do it eight times
one
two
three
four
7.
eight
okay good now we do it again with
weight on the left but without support
on our own
so now it's really important to engage
the core
yeah the middle of your body
okay let's do it eight times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay now with the other leg weight
on the right and the left
behind and we do it three times
one
two
[Music]
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay eight times with each leg
with support and without support let's
go to the next exercise
okay in the second exercise we will do a
full ulcer forward with heel first but
we will do it very slowly
first supporting ourselves on the wall
and then without support
so put your fingers on the wall and the
exercise is like this
you stand on the left leg and you
already start the exercise
with the hip rotated in the direction of
the first step
and the first movement i do is the
projection of the free leg
yeah of course bend the standing leg
because then you can project further
and then this is the first movement
projection
the second movement is sliding
the front foot a little bit by pushing
with a standing leg yeah you push here
so you slide the free leg and then
transfer weight
this is the next movement transfer
weight
the next movement is the pivot with the
hip
and you keep the free food
separated from the standing food you
don't close them in zero position not
yet
yeah you trace a circle
on the floor yeah and the next movement
is closing the free foot in zero
position
yeah so we have projection
slide and transfer of weight pivot with
hip
and close yeah projection
slide and transfer hip with pivot
and close l4 movements
now how does this work with the
metronome because on the metronome we
have
two beats and one of them is strong one
two one two so the first thing we need
to do is to decide
which one of these movements of the
sequence is the strong one
is the main movement and for me in this
combination
the main movement is the transfer of
weight
that's the strong movement one
so this will be the one one that means
that the projection
which comes before has to be on the end
before yes so and one
so after this comes the pivot and
and then comes closing in zero position
two
so we have and one
and two and
one and two
and one and two you see so the step
the transfer of weight is the one
is a strong movement and
two okay now
another tip is that although we are
placing movements in beads very
precisely
you should still keep the flow of the
movement you should not cut it
don't do the exercise like this and
one and two and
one yeah don't cut it because
this is wrong and it doesn't let you
practice
the movement of the free leg yeah
you should keep the free leg always in
movement
always in movement and one
and two and one
and two yeah so you have to adjust your
speed
so that you can hit each moment of the
metronome
at the right time without cutting your
flow
okay so we will do it eight times to
each side
first with the wall and then eight times
without the wall
okay let's do it together
very slowly following the tempo
take your time concentrate on good
technique
and on flow okay so we start with the
weight on the left
bend the knee and the hip is already
rotated
for the first step 90 degrees
parallel to the wall yeah like support
with the fingers
and we start eight times to each side
and one
one
[Music]
three
um
[Music]
seven
nine eight
and eight
okay don't forget to use the torch
the middle yeah so that you don't move
the torso
yeah that you remove the torso too much
now we will do it without the wall on
our own so
get ready wait on the left bend the knee
hip already parallel to the wall for the
first step
and we do it eight times to each side
yeah
now it's really important to use the
torso
okay
one
and one
two
and two
and three
on five
on six
five six
on seven
[Music]
okay one last tip yeah
sorry one last tip is that when you're
doing the pivot remember
don't open the arms yeah usually what
happens is that if you are doing the
pivot
twisting your hip to the right the right
arm will have the tendency to open
like this yeah and when you do the pivot
to the left
the left arm will have the tendency to
open so
try to avoid that try to keep both arms
front yeah when you do the pivot don't
open this arm now
keep it front and when you do the other
pivot
be careful with this arm keep it front
yeah
don't open them okay let's go to the
next exercise
okay so in this exercise we will
practice the full launcher forward
with hip first in half time so faster
yeah so it will be the same as the
previous
exercise yeah you start with the weight
on the left you bend the knee you
already have the hip
oriented in the in the direction of the
first step
and then you project transfer with
people keeping the distance between free
food
and standing food and then close yeah
and one and two
but in half time so
the first thing we will do is to add a
subdivision
to our tempo so it will sound like this
because we will use this supervision
in this way we will start
with the first movement with the
projection and this will be the end
and one and two and one
and two and one and two and one
yeah so you have projection transfer
period cross projection transfer
keyboard close projection transfer
keyboard close
yeah same as before but just faster
okay so we will do it with the wall
16 times yeah because now we are using
half the time for each one
and then without the wall 16 times as
well
and now it's really important that you
use your
um core yeah that you squeeze it
on each field to keep the speed and to
keep the balance
okay so let's do it
with a wall
16 times so get ready
fingers on the wall very light support
weight on the
left bend the knee and you already have
the hip
in the direction of the first step
and one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight
one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight
okay now without the work
and here balance will be a challenge
yeah
because there is a lot of movement in a
short time so
i give you three tips to help with your
balance the first one
bend the standing leg yeah
just do the whole exercise with uh
bent knees and low the second
use your torso squeeze it don't move the
torso move it as little as you can and
use the core keep it tight
and squeeze it because this will help
your balance
a lot and the third remember
that when you step yeah
your goal is to put your head on top
of the standing foot yeah you have to
reach this position head on top of the
foot
if you reach this position you will be
able to do this movement
which has a lot of inertia without
falling over
okay so let's try 16 times
without the wall put your weight on the
left
the hip is already oriented the torso is
to the wall
and bending
and one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight eight more
one one
two two
three three
four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight
okay good
this was challenging but if you had
problems with this exercise
don't worry because first of all if you
have a metronome
and you do it later on your own you can
always lower the tempo
yeah and then work in increments until
you reach this speed you can also do it
with music
and try different orchestras yeah it's
four movements four beats
yeah and the second thing is that don't
give up
you know practice practice sometimes the
reason
that i don't upload videos so often is
because i'm practicing myself because
i'm not happy yet with how i'm showing
it
so it takes me also some days to
practice until i can show it
so i'm sure that if you do it one day
and you are not so happy with how it
feels if you keep doing it
another day and another day by the third
day
you will feel a difference it will feel
easier okay
so keep practicing let's go to the next
exercise
okay in this exercise we will start
working with our auto forward
using leg first and like before we will
focus on the moment of the pivot
yeah so the exercises like this
first with support on the wall with the
fingers
you put your weight on the left just
like before you flex the knee
and you put your free foot behind like
this yeah with some distance and make
sure that your heel is not falling down
to the outside yeah keep it straight
now instead of moving the hip first
you are going to move the leg first like
this you will do
a lapis going forward on the floor
yeah like a circle try this movement a
few times
yeah one one like a pendulum
yeah lay on the floor going forward like
this now
you will feel that the movement of the
leg
generates a kind of inertia yeah like
this at the end
there is an inertia and this inertia you
will use
to rotate your hip yeah so
the movement of the leg helps the hip
to rotate leg hip yeah
leg hip
leg hip now if you do it right
you should feel that the rotation of the
hip takes almost no
effort at all yeah why because
you are not using anymore the muscles of
your core
to rotate the hip like this or like this
yeah you are actually using the leg
the movement of the leg to help
rotate the hip with the inertia so the
rotation of the hip is very very easy
yeah so how does this work with the
metal room with the two beads that we
have
one and two and
so the movement of the leg will be the
one
one and and then to come back
first we will rotate the hip and then we
will place the foot
so it will be one and
two and one and
two one up
two and like this okay
eight times with right leg then with
left
and then eight times again with each leg
without the wall okay
so we go back to our
simple beat without suit divisions
just two bits per bar and let's do it
together
put your weight on the left bend the
knee
don't move the torso and
fingers on the wall less than eight
times with leg first
one
[Music]
two
three slowly
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay try not to mix the movements
and first move the leg completely as far
as you can
yeah and then at the very end
you turn the hip yeah work clean
especially now that you have a lot of
time with this slow tempo
okay let's do it with the right leg
weight on the right and
bend the knee put the foot behind and
then
we start with the leg okay eight times
one
two
three
four
five don't rush
six
seven
eight
okay now without the wall
put your weight on the left bend the
knee
that will help you with stability
place the arms and let's do it eight
times
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay now it turns to the right put your
weight on the right flex the knee
place the left foot behind a little bit
eight times
starting with the leg okay
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
okay great now one last tip is that
maybe you feel that one side feels
better than the other yeah feels
easier for example with me i feel that
when i breathe with the right leg
this feels for me very comfortable and
with the left
it feels a bit weird but this is normal
and this is all in your mind yeah both
legs are the same
what happens is that you are more used
to
use one leg as an active leg to do
movements
uh with one leg yeah for example for me
is the
right so but this is normal and what you
should do
is work on your weak side yeah do an
extra repetition of
eight times with your weak side until
you find it
yeah trust the movement and the
natural feeling that you feel with your
good leg will come to the weak layer
also
let's go to the next exercise okay in
this exercise we will do the full auto
forward with leg first
slowly yeah first with support on the
wall
so the exercise will be like this then
as we did before
you start with a weight on your left
leg a little bit flex and the hip is
already
oriented in the direction of the first
step yeah
like it's parallel to the wall so the
first movement that you do
is the projection of the leg like this
yeah then you push with a standing leg
you push backwards
so that your free foot slides forward a
little bit yeah
slides forward and then you change the
weight you do the step this is the main
influence
when you are here you don't move the hip
you move the leg first you do the
slapping forward
and the inertia of this movement you can
try a little bit
yeah rotate your hip at the end
yeah so you start with the leg and then
you rotate the hip
and you close the foot in zero position
and then from here
you go again the projection yeah so it's
projection change weight
leg and hip projection
step leg and hip
projection step leg
and hip yeah when you do layer here
don't mix the movements yeah
first do the whole lapis on the floor
until your foot is
almost crossing the standing foot
yeah and then you move the heat
yeah okay so we will do it
eight times to each side one one two two
three feet like before
first with the wall and then without the
wall okay
so uh let's do it together
eight times slowly so
get ready put your weight on the left
bend the knee
and the torso all the time to the wall
yeah try not to move it
try not moving uh at all if you can
yeah and we start with the projection
um one
one
and two
five
and six
and seven
on seven
on eight
and eight
okay now we will do it without the walls
so remember the tips to keep your
balance when you do it
without the support of the wall first
bend the knee of the standing leg this
will help your stability
second engage your core your torch
your your middle yeah especially
when you are doing the
leg and pivot yeah you really need
to have your core tight this will help
you with the balance
and the third try to
put your he your head on top of your
foot
as soon as you can after you do the step
and
don't forget your standing leg because
this movement with the leg has a lot of
inertia
and it can get you out of your balance
so when you are moving the free leg
remember the standing leg
yeah so that you don't lose the balance
okay so let's do it together
put your weight on the left hip
in the direction of the first step
without the wall eight times
um one
and one
slowly uh two don't rush
and three three open downs
three
um four
keep downs forward four
uh five
ah five
six
on six
on seven
five seven
and eight
okay good very good
so let's go to the last exercise
okay in the last exercise we will do the
full motion forward with leg first
but in half time so faster so the
exercise is the same as before
you start with your weight on the left
leg with the knee bend
the hip is already looking in the
direction of the first step
and then you have the projection push
and slide
transition weight for the step leg and
hip yeah but it's going to be
faster so it's going to be projection
step
leg key projection step leg key
projection stand
leg key injection step leg keep
like this yeah remember that the step
is the main movement is the movement
that we do on the strong beat
one um step yeah
that means that the projection is going
to be on the iron yeah
in our bedroom we set an extra
subdivision
so it sounds like this and one
yeah and step
so you are going to have
this projection set like hip projection
step
leg hip projection step leg projection
like he that's how it is okay so we do
it
16 times now to each side because we are
using half the time for each repetition
first with support on the wall and then
times again with out the wall on our own
okay so let's start get ready put your
weight on the left
hip is in this way and try to keep
the torso oriented towards the wall as
much as you can
okay let's go and
one and one
and two and two
and three and three
and four and four
and five and five
and six and six
and seven and seven
eight and eight eight more
and one one
two two
three three
four four
five five
six six
seven seven
eight eight
okay good now we do it without
the wall and remember the tips flex your
knee
that will help engage your core yeah
like your life depends on it
yeah because it will really help you
with your balance
and try to put your head on top of your
standing foot when you finish the step
and concentrate on your standing leg
when you are
throwing your free leg around so that
the free leg doesn't
pull you out of balance okay so
let's go let's go get ready
wait on the left and we do it 16 times
and one and one
and two and two
and three and three
and four and four
and five and five
and six and six
and seven and seven
and eight and eight
eight more and one and
one and two
and two and three
and three and four
and four and five
negative and five leg kick
six leg hip six leg
hip seven leg kick
seven leg here hey leg
hip eight leg hip
okay good
very good very good okay so
um now to finish a few tips how can you
use this
yeah that's always the question so for
followers
if you want to use the ocho forward with
leg
first this is tricky because
imagine that you're dancing with a guy
with a man
and he leads you a pivot for a nature
forward so
all of us have learned and are
programmed to react with our hip
the moment you feel the man leaning in
the pivot
you are used to react with the hip yeah
so you have to unlearn this and
learn to react with the leg so how it
works is like this
the moment that you feel that the man is
leading you the change of direction
the pivot yeah what you do after the
torso turns because of his lift yeah you
cannot avoid it
is that you throw the leg yeah you don't
react with the hip but you
throw the leg outside yeah
that's the first thing that happens well
this is what you have to learn
if you can do this with the leg the rest
happens by itself
boom yeah your hip comes
yeah but that's the difficult thing for
the follower for the woman
to break this connection between torso
and hip
and send what happens on the torso
to the leg yeah and delaying the hip
retain the hip yeah so that's for the
follower for the man for the leader how
can he use this especially
the ultra forward with leg first well
there is a very cool
thing that you can do as a man with this
movement
and is when you want to do a sakada to
the woman
using a side step yeah imagine that you
are
in a heel in a turn and the woman is
doing some step around you
she can be doing her front step around
you or her side step
around you or her back step around you
but you want to do a sakada to that step
using a side step so usually what you do
is if you are leading the woman around
you yeah
and she's doing a step and you want to
cut that step with a
what you do is you do a pivot and you
realize that
boom saka